[Music]  once everything was awesome  now everything is okay Lucy I brought  you coffee coffee the bitter liquid that  provides the only semblance of pleasure  left in these dark times oh my gosh did  I interrupt you brooding just now  times have changed you need to change  with them we have to be tough and  battle-ready  [Music]  berry the door is slowly closing  [Music]  [Applause]  we're going after trainer I don't get it  we'll help me rescue my friends only the  toughest you're gonna get out of there  alive  i'm mcqueen whatever I would Nobby  I'm getting super evil vibes here I  could change my form to something else  if this makes you uncomfortable  hey guys they'll go back  don't worst was much more palatable  [Music]  did you draw double dots on your face  who are you I'm your worst nightmare  Oh me when I'm late to school and I  forgot my homework and my pants are made  of pudding  no I don't  [Music]